como les había dicho les traería un
problema más interesante sobre la
composición en peso de alguna fórmula
empírica uno que no sea complicado y
aquí está tenemos esta composición de
una mezcla en estado líquido en donde
hay dos puntos 0 4 % de hidrógeno 65.3
de oxígeno y 32.65 de azufre esta es la
fórmula empírica de una sustancia
entonces lo que haremos como siempre en
este tipo de problemas vamos a suponer
que tenemos 100 gramos de esta sustancia
100 gramos
vamos a ponerlo de color amarillo
si tenemos 100 gramos en total de la
sustancia cuántos gramos de hidrógeno
tenemos bueno en 100 gramos tenemos 2.04
gramos de hidrógeno
65 punto 3 gramos de oxígeno
y 32 65 gramos de azufre
a continuación tenemos que calcular
cuántos moles de hidrógeno es esto
cuántos moles de oxígeno y cuántos de
azufre para poder compararla este
geometría que conoceremos de la fórmula
empírica
así que cuál es la masa de un molde
hidrógeno
bueno un bol de hidrógeno sabemos que la
masa molecular del hidrógeno es 1 así
como su número atómico especialmente
porque es el primer elemento de la tabla
periódica a nivel molecular si hacemos
un estudio en la tierra observaremos que
el hidrógeno tiene un núcleo neutro
tiene un electrón pero no tiene
neutrones así que tiene una masa atómica
de un solo átomo cuando decimos que
tenemos un gran mol de hidrógeno un
molde hidrógeno en realidad tenemos 6.0
2 por 10 a la 23 moléculas de hidrógeno
así que si un molde es igual a un gramo
por mol cuántos gramos de hidrógeno
tenemos entonces tenemos 2.04 moles de
hidrógeno atención si miramos aquí
observamos que tenemos 2.04 gramos de
hidrógeno
tomando en cuenta que un mole es igual a
un gramo entonces tenemos 2.04 moles de
hidrógeno esto al multiplicarlo por 6.0
2 por 10 a la 23 nos da los átomos de
hidrógeno que tenemos al final ahora un
molde de oxígeno vamos a escribirlo la
masa del oxígeno por si lo han olvidado
es 16 aquí está 16 la masa del oxígeno
es de 16 unidades atómicas entonces un
molde oxígeno es igual a 16 gramos para
saber cuántos moles de oxígeno hay
tenemos
65.3 gramos vamos a notarlo 65.3 gramos
de oxígeno / vamos a dividirlo entre 16
gramos por mol que nos da un resultado
de 4.08 125 no necesitamos ser tan
precisos podemos dejarlo en 4.08 moles
de oxígeno
4.08 moles de oxígeno y finalmente el
azufre cual es la masa atómica del
azufre algo que nunca olvidaré del
azufre en su olor hay una ciudad de
luisiana al que le llaman puerto de
azufre por software donde hacían un
montón de procesos con azufre por ahí
por suerte para los que ahora viven ahí
ya solucionaron el problema pero antes
olía mucho a azufre que huele como a
huevos podridos y regresando al problema
un molde azufre que está justo ahí la
masa atómica es de 32 unidades atómicas
por átomo de azufre así que un molde
azufre es igual a 32 gramos entonces
un molde azufre pulmón es igual a 32
gramos mol de azufre igual a 32 gramos
entonces cuántos gramos de azufre
tenemos bueno vamos a ver tenemos 32
vamos a notarlo 32.65 gramos de azufre
/ vamos a dividirlos entre treinta y dos
gramos por mol entonces tenemos que en
32 puntos 65 gramos de azufre hay 1.02
moles de azufre
así que tenemos que por cada átomo de
azufre quiero comentarles que ya había
resuelto este problema antes y les puedo
decir que estos resultados son correctos
por cada molde azufre es decir por cada
6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 átomos de azufre
tenemos 2.04 moles de hidrógeno la
relación es que por cada molde azufre
tenemos dos moles de hidrógeno dos veces
1.02 es 2.04 y por cada molde azufre hay
cuatro moles de oxígeno es decir cuatro
veces
entonces la proporción de hidrógeno
azufre y oxígeno es que por cada uno de
azufre tenemos dos de hidrógeno y cuatro
oxígenos entonces la fórmula molecular
de esto es h2so4
h 2 tenemos un azufre y 4 de oxígeno
h2so4 esto es ácido sulfúrico una de las
cosas que estoy segura no querrían tocar
espero les haya sido útil